and went welcome to this video playing
international Serbian Arlanda from
Sweden surprisingly I have not played
him before but I have seen him on only I
see quite frequently so it's a bit of a
surprise that they happened I didn't
know did not yet play against him it's
possible that he is not regular in the
5-minute pool and that sometimes happens
people mostly play 3-minute or not in
the pool at all
okay Queen b3 oh my god and that is a
move of course Wow well I don't remember
I think this is actually a cup of game
mmm is six or not I really don't
remember there is an idea with Knight
takes e4 I wonder if this is this is the
position Knight takes Knight takes
Bishop takes d5 Queen is hanging neither
saying bishop is hanging there is this
idea but oh my god I don't know if it's
here I want some other point
94-94 5523 maybe he has
[Music]
I have absolutely no recollection how
this works
give me three isn't even all that great
but if they don't remember why I mean
not like it's totally terrible or so
that that definitely not the case but I
think black should be okay but I don't
remember anything I don't remember
anything at all yeah it's been more than
a year then since I compared to the
Bangko repertoire and of course I've
played it quite a bit in blitz chess and
some lots of tournament games but you
don't get all the lines and you get some
some some variations are seen more
frequently and some are rare and rare
ones I tend to forget I always have to
check a Bishop d7 check you know but I
can take with the knight cover my queen
yeah I'm not sure what's going on here I
am if he goes Bishop c4 I can take b3
and grab on d5 I think I mean I'm a
little bit underdeveloped okay so he
allows me to take this that is
interesting
hmm at the end this possibly anyway I
have to do this
so okay Wow
really what is this doing why is this a
good move I mean you see he's not
threatening a check with the night
there's no discovery if I can I don't
just take him sorry I don't get it
you mean the whole center is falling
apart him I'm just the development is
not good of course but still it's hard
to believe that black shouldn't be
betting in this position okay I didn't
didn't see this move coming but okay
this one 97 I take takes there should be
three
23 I go see four yeah but sure before I
was a bad miss I didn't really think
about this move and it's a pretty simple
move
I don't really see a good reply to be
honest at least nothing great I mean we
can check on c7 Queen takes Queen d5
something like that he can do check okay
so to do it yeah and now I was thinking
I just take care with the pawn she takes
on c7 it's interesting I have I have I
have this trying to trap the bishop that
is an interesting idea
King bee seven and king king to c6 is
good anyway I'm covering d5 so he will
do this the setup which is not all that
great Bishop here to f6 see doing before
maybe haven't been yeah there is a move
that is a move actually okay
maybe maybe I haven't strayed this
tough position true but he has to take
on most right 92 is a really strange
choice and it is played of was
fulfilling time morning understimated
really
that should be good how to believe that
those pawns shouldn't be very nice
that's actually a Czech home it is
actually a Czech Czech 20 seconds
check I'm totally winning here with the
pawns I think but you still have to do
it check check
check
yeah I'm losing shine completely
ridiculous after the skin check check
check
game drawn okay it's the kind of gamma
to sucks him it just sucks anyway so
well let's have a look so we had to very
hit something here yeah so I can't take
that I couldn't couldn't couldn't quite
remember this this this this and then f5
or Queen Suzanne so this is the thing
yeah I didn't remember this I knew that
there was a line with Knight takes e4
which essentially is refueling the white
setup at least when it comes to playing
for an advantage but I couldn't remember
it I got this far but I didn't see f5 or
Queen to b7 no there is there is this
and you have a d5 at the end and also in
five I can play both okay so for next
time but he 95 now would have would have
won for white is pretty awful well he
didn't do it obviously no check
yeah yeah yeah like is just completely
winning okay the engine is just like on
one pawn but if you give it more time
those two Center pawns you should just
win now I became in the game was totally
clear after that but I had spent lots of
time in the opening phase after having
forgotten who the whole line yeah but
yeah it's kind of pointless to look at
it's completely winning but the time was
an issue okay guys thanks for watching